viéndose a una lista creciente de
estados de eeuu dirigidos por demócratas
nuevayork levanta parte de su mandato de
mascarillas en espacios cerrados la
gobernadora liberal de nueva york
anunció el miércoles que el requisito de
vacuna o máscara en todo el estado
terminará agregó que a medida que la
cantidad de nuevas infecciones y
hospitalizaciones disminuyen
constantemente ahora es posible relajar
las reglas
neoyorquinos esto es lo que estábamos
esperando un progreso tremendo después
de dos largos años y aún no hemos
terminado pero esto va en una muy muy
buena dirección y es por eso que ahora
nos acercamos a una nueva fase en esta
pandemia a partir del jueves todas las
empresas restaurantes y lugares de
entretenimiento del estado de nueva york
pueden eliminar el requisito de
mascarilla dejando su uso a una decisión
personal pero no es probable que la
medida afecte lugares con un requisito
federal de uso de mascarilla como el
transporte público y las instalaciones
de atención médica en las escuelas
seguirá siendo obligatorio hasta que
haya una próxima revisión en la ciudad
más poblada de eeuu la medida de
protección generalmente muy respetada ya
que la ciudad de nueva york fue el
epicentro de la pandemia en 2020 y
personalmente creo que es mejor prevenir
que lamentar y seguir usando mi
mascarilla hasta que los números del
virus se bajen un poco más
las mascarillas siguen siendo un tema
divisivo en eeuu mientras el país se
prepara para las elecciones intermedias
clave a finales de este año si bien
previamente los demócratas lideraron la
aplicación de los mandatos de
mascarillas los estados republicanos
llegaron incluso a prohibir las de forma
obligatoria